hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte heute mal wieder
einen klassiker machen und zwar erst
richtig einfacher klassiker der glaube
ich auch jedermann schmeckt denn ich
mache heute eine maulwurf torte da wurde
ich echt schon ganz oft danach gefragt
weil das produkt gibt es ja als
fertigprodukt im supermarkt zu kaufen
aber man kann es auch wirklich ganz
einfach selber machen
ich werde das ganze jetzt mit einem
leckeren rührteig machen und zeigt euch
jetzt mal ganz kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier 130 gramm zimmer warme
butter
ich habe hier vier eier und bereits
aufgeteilt in eigelb und eiweiß 130
gramm zucker
hier habe ich noch ein glas milch das
ist auch zimmer warm dann wieder vanille
essens- und etwas salz also gerade so
eine prise dann habe ich hier drüben 50
gramm kakaopulver 50 gramm speisestärke
70 gramm mehl und dann nur noch eine
packung backpulver
ich mache das ganze jetzt mit einem
rührteig aber ich werde die eier trennen
und zuerst das eiweiß aufschlagen
damit der rührteig einfach etwas
luftiger wird und deswegen gebe ich
jetzt ist eiweiß in eine kleine schüssel
oder eine große schüssel gebt dann eine
prise salz dazu das hilft dass die
eiweiße struktur schneller zerstört wird
und dass ein schnee richtig schnell eben
entsteht und das lasse ich jetzt ganz
kurz stören
und wenn der schnee dann steif ist dann
gebe ich noch etwa die hälfte des
zuckers mit dazu und lass es noch einmal
etwa eine minute verrühren
und jetzt ist das ganze richtig schön
steif und ich kann es kurz zur seite
stellen
und jetzt nehme ich mir eine andere
schüssel und nehme auch hier diesen
flexibler also ein flach hörer und nicht
mehr den schneebesen und da hat hier so
eine gummilippe tragen und da bleibt
einfach nichts mehr am rand kleben von
der schüssel sondern man bekommt
wirklich alles mit untergerührt und
deswegen nehmen wir es erst mal die
butter gleich auch ganz wichtig dass die
zimmer warm ist sonst lässt sie sich
nicht so gut verrühren und die verhöre
ich jetzt kurzem in zu kommen es sieht
man ja auch gleich da wird es echt alles
vom rand mitgenommen von dieser
gummilippe mit geben wir dann auf die
eignung und hier gebe ich jetzt noch
mein mann ist ein geradezu ein paar
tropfen der sich nämlich hoch
konzentriert man kann aber auch zum
beispiel vanillezucker oder etwas abrieb
von der etwas vanille markt nehmen
und ich gebe jetzt hier mein backpulver
zu meiner stärke oder zum mehl mit dazu
einfach um das ganz kurz miteinander zu
verrühren
dass sich das backpulver schön verteilen
kann
und jetzt gebe ich die trockenen zutaten
einfach alle gemeinsam mit in diese
schüssel rein also mail stärke
backpulver und kakaopulver und lass es
jetzt bei niedriger stufe verrühren und
gibt währenddessen mensch dazu und da
nehmen wir einfach so viel biss einfach
in geschmeidiger teig entsteht der nicht
zu flüssig sein darf denn der schnee mit
der gleich noch unter gehoben
und den rest mache ich jetzt per hand
sobald sich sowieso die trockenen
zutaten vermischt haben müsste aufhören
zu rühren
damit das ganze nicht so klebrig wird
und jetzt früher ich hier den eischnee
ein auf etwa zwei bis drei portionen
einfach mitnimmt aber unterheben
und wenn sich jetzt alles vermengt hat
nehme ich meine springform ihr könnt
auch einen bug rahmen backen
aber ich nehme jetzt einfach heute mal
die springform um euch das auch so zu
zeigen
ich habe den boden bereits gefettet mit
meinem back trend spray einfach ganz nah
an gesprüht und etwas mit einem pinsel
verteilt und jetzt habe ich hier etwas
mehl damit das ganze einfach nicht dran
haftet also der teig an der springform
und jetzt wird es hier so ein bisschen
verteilt und hierbei ist einfach wichtig
dass immer nur der boden der springform
eben mit dem mehl und mit dem fett
beschichtet wird damit einfach am rand
der teig schön hochklettern kann und
nicht immer zusammen fällt dann bekommt
er nämlich auch kein jubel in dem kuchen
und er wird schön glatt so jetzt fühle
ich da den teig schnell ein
und verteilt den jetzt einfach in der
form in der mitte gerne etwas weniger
als ich mache das gern so dass am rand
mehr teig ist und in der mitte weniger
so könnt ihr den hobel nämlich auch
vermeiden und jetzt gebe ich den teig so
in meinen vorgeheizten backofen bei etwa
180 grad ober und unterhitze für
ungefähr 25 minuten dann sollte er durch
sein
ihr könnt auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen mit einem zahnstocher und
wenn nichts mehr dran klebt dann ist
fertig ich habe meinen kopf und bereits
auf eine abkühlung gitter abkühlen
lassen und jetzt werde ich denen etwas
aufschneiden und aushöhlen damit ich
gleich ein paar brösel habe für meinen
maulwurfshügel der wird nämlich später
mit sarah gefühlt und dann kommen da die
böse drüber sieht dann aus wie so ein
echter maulwurfshügel dafür nehme ich
mir zum messer und schneider jetzt
ringsherum etwa einen zentimeter also
klassischen zentimeter platz wo jetzt
schneiden ringsrum ein so etwa ein
halben zentimeter tief am besten mit so
einer drehbewegung das müsst ihr auch
auf jeden fall machen als es reicht
nicht einfach einen deckel abzuschneiden
und das ganze dann zu zerbröseln
weil dann läuft er später die füllung
raus und wir wollen ja dass der hügel
später richtig schön aussieht
jetzt nehme ich mir einen löffel und
katze jetzt hier innen das vorsichtig
aus und das ganze wie gesagt etwa einen
halben zentimeter tief
den kuchen stelle ich jetzt kurz zur
seite und diese direkt reste also die
kuchen reste die zerbröselt jetzt kurz
mit den händen
aber er soll sie nicht zerdrücken denn
dann wärst du mir so eine cache pop
masse sondern einfach nur ganz locker
zerkrümeln und später benutzen wir die
dann gleich weiter
und jetzt kann ich meine führung
herstellen und brauche dafür auch nur
ganz wenige zutaten
ich nehme 600 gramm schlagsahne weiß
nicht komplett mit schlagsahne machen
möchte kann zum beispiel auch ein
päckchen sahne also 200 gramm durch
etwas quark ersetzen
dann habe ich hier etwas salat zum sahne
steifen zwei esslöffel butter zucker
ich nehme wieder meinen manila sense 3
bis 4 bananen und ich habe hier ein paar
schoko drops da könnte auch ganz einfach
schokoraspeln benutzen
ich mache jetzt einfach komplett nur mit
sahne damit das ganze schön leicht
schmeckt aber ich bin auch ein großer
fan von quark krems als er möchte kann
auch wirklich einen teil durch clarke
ersetzen
dann schmeckt auch etwas säuerlicher und
ihr könnt auch zum beispiel statt der
bananen einfach etwas sauerkirschen
nehmen oder auch mandarinen oder
irgendwie ein anderes obst was euch eben
gut schmeckt jetzt habe ich spritzschutz
drauf damit da nix raus spritzt oder
fast nichts und lasse die sahne ganz
kurz verrühren und gibt dann gleich etwa
fünf teelöffel vom salat dazu bis die
sahne einfach komplett steif ist
hier gebe ich jetzt auch noch den
puderzucker mehr dazu und bessern etwas
süßer mag nimmt einfach ein bisschen
und natürlich auch dass vanille aroma
mit ein
die sanis jetzt steig ich stelle sie
ganz kurz zur seite und nehme jetzt
meine bananen
die werden jetzt erst mal geschehen und
dann einfach längs halbiert und die
legen wir dann direkt auf den kuchen
drauf falls ihr zum beispiel
sauerkirschen oder anderes obst nimmt
müsste einfach darauf achten dass vorher
richtig gut abtropfen zu lassen
ansonsten wird nämlich der kuchen
richtig nass jetzt halte ich die einmal
längs und legt sie jetzt direkt auf den
kuchen drauf
und jetzt nehme ich einfach nur noch
meine schoko drops und entweder könnte
die jetzt in die creme rein also
unterheben
oder ihr können sie direkt auf die
bananen streuen ich glaube ich mache
einfach beides ich gebe jetzt einen teil
über die bananen direkt rüber ich mag
das nämlich wenn die dann so beim
reinbeißen so ein bisschen knacken
deswegen nehme ich auch gerne diese
schoko drops und den rest gebe ich es
einfach hier dass du jetzt mal nicht
komplett alle und hebt die ganz kurz
unter und gibt dann direkt die sahne auf
meine torte drauf
das sieht jetzt alles nach sehr viel
sahne aus aber wir brauchen hier auch
ein bisschen messer damit zum schöner
maulwurfshügel wird weil sie jetzt etwas
weniger sahne haben wollt nehmt einfach
weniger aber dann gibt's halt kein
schöner maulwurfshügel und jetzt einfach
am rand entlang streichen so ein
bisschen runter und dann können wir das
gleich schön formen
und bevor ich jetzt da die krümel drauf
setze ich meine torte erstmal auf eine
schöne platte das geht entweder mit
einem torten retter ganz gut oder mit so
nem mit seinem mit sonar winkel palette
mein gott heute mit über das so und
jetzt kommen noch die kuchen brösel
drüber ganz süß weiß auch wenn man jetzt
zum beispiel aus marzipan oder von dann
so einen kleinen böses tier maulwurf
wenn man ballwurf modelliert jetzt
einfach die krümel andrücken
ich kann jetzt meine maulwurf order
anschneiden ich hatte dass sie jetzt
etwa 1 bis eineinhalb stunden im
kühlschrank natürlich schmeckt sie umso
besser je kälter das sie ist aber ich
denke sie ist so schon kalt genug und
ich kann sie direkt an schneiden und da
freue ich mich auch schon richtig drauf
denn ich hatte echt schon lange keinen
maulwurfs kuchen mehr
ich glaube den letzten hat man mein
bruder gemacht und es war noch so eine
fertigpackungen und ich habe ewig keinen
ärger macht wirklich ewig ein großes
stück das wetter auch schön rein gucken
können
derzeit brüssel zwar so ein bisschen
beim schneiden
aber ich finde anschaut kann sich sehen
lassen und vor allen dingen stephanie
ist einfach so fest dass er nicht in
sich zusammenfällt durch der die sahne
stärke also durch das saunabad und man
kann es einfach schön aufschneiden und
auch mal gerne stehen lassen weil der
bub hat jetzt einfach gar nicht da ich
probiere ich einfach hotels ganz alleine
da steht nämlich auf dem balkon und
telefoniert grad geben dann seinen weg
macht irgendwie umso mehr spaß und ich
muss sagen dass ich so da mal was kuchen
sowie ich ihn auch kennen der boden ist
richtig schön locker und schokoladig
dann kommen die leckeren bananen ich
liebe auch mal bananen und dann eben
diese leckeren schokostückchen in der
lockeren sahne
er ist für mich ist es ein richtig
runter kuchen oder 100 orte ihr könnt
ihr natürlich auch abwandeln indem er zb
ein paar haselnüsse noch mit in den teig
gibt oder einfach anderes obst nehmen zu
wie ist eben schon gesagt habe und
könnte ihn einfach abhandeln ich würde
mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr mir ein
bild auf instagram oder auf facebook
schickt natürlich mit dem hashtag sally
stalken welt damit ich das auch alles
sehe und natürlich zurück kommentieren
kann und das komplette rezept gibt es
dann auch sallys - blog.de und ich freue
mich schon aufs nächste mal wieder
fußball teams